This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's the end of the year and time for our annual mini stories episodes. Mini stories are quick hit stories that were maybe pitched to us from someone in the audience or something interesting we saw on Twitter or just a cool tidbit that we found in our research that just got stuck in our heads and wouldn't come out. But they didn't quite warrant the full episode treatment for whatever reason. There also this great opportunity for us to get to know the non-scripted version of the fine people who work on this show, and as the person who gets to interview them, that is my favorite part of this. We have some real charmer's on staff. We'll have stories of mysterious ice boats,
green ruins, sacked dresses, steampunk violins, and a little update from a couple of the notable city flags that have been redesigned around the country. It's going to be fun. First up is senior producer, Katie Mingle. So, okay, we're going to start out by meeting Denise. Hi, my name is Denise Boniface, and I own Aquanux diving in Rocky Mountain House, Alberta, Canada. Yeah, so Denise is from Alberta, Canada, where she owns a scuba diving company. And Alberta, as you may know, is not a coastal province. So if you're scuba diving in Alberta, you're doing it in lakes.
They're cold, they're dark, they're murky, they're kind of creepy. Sounds delightful. Sometimes. So there's this one lake called Lake Patricia. Surrounded by mountains, it's right in a mountain valley, very, very remote. And if you find the right spot on the lake
and dive about 30 feet down, you'll find a shipwreck. It doesn't really look like a ship. It looks like there's a pile of lumber that's all broken up and laying there. And then there's a lot of refrigeration coils. What are the refrigeration coils for? We're going to get to that, but just, okay, for now, so you make your way down sort of through this murky darkness, this like pile of lumber and debris. 50 feet, 60 feet. And then you'll find a plaque.
Oh. Right? This is where her home and gets excited. It's pitch dark, but if you shine a light on it, you can read it and Denise has read it. Plot says operations have a cut. A secret World War II project involving the use of ice and ship construction. The special built January to April 1943 was a prototype. Some more information contacts the Canadian Park Service
jasker. Wow, so there's like a hyperlink in the bottom of a lake. WWW dot, yeah there's a QR code. Okay, so there's so many things about this plaque that I love. I love that it's at the bottom of a lake I love the part where it says for more info contact the Canadian Park Service because it sort of implies you could just Dumble across this while like strolling at the bottom of a Canadian lake And then I actually I asked Denise that and she was like, yeah, you could because there's a lot of people that tied in this lake but of course the most intriguing part of the plaque is the part about the secret World War II project
involving the use of ice in ship construction. So what was that about? So, okay, so in the early 1940s during World War II, German submarines, or U-boats as they were called, were basically wreaking havoc on allied ships in the Atlantic Ocean, just sinking them left and right. And so eventually this person named Admiral Mount Batten goes to Winston Churchill and he's like, we have to do something about this. And I think I know what this solution is. A giant, unsinkable aircraft carrier sized ship made of ice. Of course.
Right. And actually, Churchill is intrigued. Like, it sounds like one of those far-fetched ideas that kind of gets floated during times war, but never actually gets built, except for this really did get built, or at least a prototype of it got built, and that is the shipwreck at the bottom of Patricia Lake, and that's what the plaque commemorates. Wow. So what in the world made Admiral Mountbatten think that an unsinkable ship should be made of ice. Yeah, so like, what the hell? Yeah, yeah, okay. It's fair enough.
Okay, so steel and aluminum were in really short supplies. So that was a big thing. They were actively looking for alternatives. And then the second thing is that they, they hoped that this ice ship would be so dense that it would basically be indestructible. And what made them think that ice would be indestructible because it doesn't seem like that. Right.
Yeah, it actually, it wasn't just plain ice. They were, they were going to build these ships out of a mixture of ice and sawdust called piecrete, named after its inventor, a guy named Jeffrey Pike. So if you mixed sort mixed water and wood chips together and then froze it, it made the ice really, really strong. And so this guy, Jeffrey Pike, he invented not only Pyecrete, but he came up with the idea of building a ship out of it. And then he got that idea to Admiral Mountbatten.
So the ships would be built from blocks of Pycrete, and then there would basically be pipes with coolant running through the whole thing. To keep it ice. Yeah, so that's the refrigerator coils that Denise saw at the bottom of the lake. And Pycrete really was this like incredibly strong and dense mixture, and there's this amazing anecdote in this story
where Admiral Mount Baton, who, again, is not the inventor of Pycrate, but he's like the main kind of evangelist for this idea. And he was so hype about it that he brings a piece of Pycrate to a meeting. This is a meeting in which they were trying to convince the Americans. So the British were trying to convince the Americans, so the British were trying to convince the Americans to get on board this crazy ice ship plan.
So he brings a block of piecrete to the meeting along with a regular block of ice. And at some point, he does this demonstration where he takes out his revolver and he shoots the regular ice and it splinters into a thousand little pieces and then he shoots the piecrete and The bullet bounces off the piecrete and actually sort of ricochets into the leg of one of his colleagues And like successful test it's actually like declared a total success and and they're all thumbs up, green light, full speed head. And yeah, they decided to go forward with this crazy plan. Winston Churchill signs off on it.
I'm not sure what all Americans signed off on it, but the Americans said, we'll help you do this. And then I guess at some point, they also got Canadians involved because they end up building this prototype on this little lake in Alberta, Canada. Lake Patricia. Yes, Lake Patricia. And they name it Project Habakkuk after a Bible verse. And I think the verse is pretty interesting, marvelously, for I am working a work in your days, which
you will not believe though it'd be told to you. Basically like the Bible verse that's like, we are building a crazy f***ing thing. And Habakkuk apparently was the name of a Hebrew prophet, which I certainly never knew. And then the prototype itself was built by Canadian conscientious objectors who didn't know what they were building and who had opted for alternative service jobs. And they were like given this job and not really told that it actually was... A worship. Yeah, for the war. and not really told that it actually was. A worship.
Yeah, for the war. So, in just a few months, they built a prototype of this ship, but it ended up being harder to build and more expensive than they thought. And by the time the prototype was ready, the war had kind of moved on. Like, they were figuring out how to build the atomic bomb.
They figured out how to mass produce smaller aircraft carriers. And in the end, they basically scrapped the project and ultimately let it sink into the bottom of Lake Patricia. And as we know, you can still see it there today. Well, the coolest thing about diving the helicopter is being able to say that you don't have a helicopter. Like, it is cool to dive it, and it's nice to see it once, but to dive it too many times, it's not that interesting, but I'm not a word to it,
but that doesn't really help you, pretty well, and does it. Yeah, so apparently, like, if you build a ship out of ice, it just sort of like turns into nothing. There's slush at the bottom of the ocean. Yeah, just. And if you've seen it once, you've seen it enough. That's fine.
That's awesome. I love that story. Special thanks to Debbie Schneiderman, who sent in the tip about Project Habacook. She actually sent it in response to the mini-stories episode that we did last year. So if you also have a mini-story suggestion, we do read them. Reach us through the contact page at 99pi.org. Next up, producer Emmett Fitzgerald.
All right, are you ready? Yeah, you should just try. I don't know what you're gonna do. Okay, so this is a story about a ruin. It's probably the most famous ruin, maybe, in the world. The Roman Colosseum. Oh, cool. You ever been?
I have never been. I've also never been. But you can picture it, right? Absolutely, you can picture it. You can picture white columns kind of dusty, denuded of all life, and it just looks like a classic ruin. Right, so what color would you say to white, maybe brown, off kind of old sand, colored stone? Totally. I think that's like, yeah, that's sort of the image we have of ruins, but I was on Twitter the other day and I found this kind of amazing thread that featured
all these paintings from the 19th century. And the Colosseum is totally green. It's like this, this greenhouse covered in vines and plants and all this different plant life. And it was a thread put together by this guy named Paul Cooper. He's a novelist and a PhD researcher at the University of East Anglia, and he studies the history of ruins. And he says that, you know, until the middle of the 19th century, the Coliseum was, yeah, I was totally overrun with plants. There were trees
and shrubs and vines growing everywhere. And, you know, like all these artists and poets would write about the Coliseum as this verdant greenhouse Charles Dickens visited the ruin and said, you know, wrote about its walls and arches overrun with green. And in the 1850s, this British botanist, a man named Richard Deacon, decides to do a botanical survey of the Coliseum, cataloging all of the plants growing on the run. Well, he found a great many plants. So over 400 species that were growing among the crumbling ruins. So that's Paul Cooper. That's the fellow, but together, the Twitter threat.
Exactly. And he told me about all the different plants that this guy Richard Nican found. 56 varieties of grass and cypresses and hollies. And yeah, just a real incredible variety. And what comes out of Deacon's book is that it's incredibly poetic description of this crumbling landscape that has become this kind of overgrown garden of great variety. It describes how it's damp and cool in the lower arcades of the Colosseum, but dry and
warm on the top layers. As you get this incredible kind of micro climate, this biodome of overflowing life. But you find specifically that some of the plants were so rare that they didn't actually occur anywhere else in Western Europe. And so Deacon sits down and he tries to sort of work out how these plants ended up in this one spot
and this iconic cultural spot is sort of a out how these plants ended up in this one spot and this like iconic cultural spot is sort of a botanical wonder. And he comes up with a kind of wild hypothesis. But these these plants must have been brought into the Colosseum on the fur or even in the stomachs of the animals that the Romans brought into the arena to fight. Romans brought in lions and they to fight gladiators and they brought in giraffes and other kinds of African wildlife for ceremonial hunts inside the Colosseum and the theory was,
as plants do, traveling on the backs of other animals that move around, that we've moved around the world, that that might be the cause of what brought these plants to the Colosseum. Oh, that's so great. It's a little hard to bear. I'm sure that was. But it's a cool story. And Paul Cooper really likes this image. There's something poetic about the idea that, you know, these ritual animal hunts, that they were held as a way of proving that humans had reached a level of civilization
that they now had complete dominion over the animals. And we'd shown that we triumped over the wild and destructive nature of the natural world, but the buried in the fur and guts of these animals were these natural seeds that were ultimately going to invade and climb over this whole magnificent ruin. So how did it happen that this, you know, verdant microclimate, almost greenhouse, become the dusty dry ruin that we think of today?
So in 1870, Italy gets unified under a secular democratic government, and they take control of the city of Rome, which had previously been in the hands of the papacy. And this new government is really trying to sort of create a sort of Rome, which had previously been in the hands of the papacy. And this new government is really trying to create a sort of rational, scientific, modern, Italian identity, but they see that as really rooted in this ancient Roman history. And so they care a lot about these old ruins like the Colosseum and projecting a certain Italianness to what these buildings represent. And the plants don't quite fit with the image that they're looking for. They see these plants as invaders that are damaging the ruins, and they begin to take
the plants off the ruins. And even at the time, there's some real pushback from scientists, from the botanical community who say, stop, this is this like special micro ecosystem filled with all these totally unique plant species. At Italian botanist and Countess, Mazzanti says that nature like to dress poetically the venerable walls and now archaeological cupidity, archaeological greed has destroyed everything. So people were giving a bit of an outcry about this at the time, but the archaeology went ahead and later on as you get into the rule of Mussolini and his fascist party, the ruin was completely stripped and excavated, completely cleaned, which is, in my view,
unfortunately, the state we find in today. So it's really about whatever you think is the proper thing to preserve. I mean, do you preserve? I mean, because it is true. The vines were destroying the room. Right. There's a certain truth to that. There is truth to that.
But what is the cost of removing all the vines and what is the history represented in the natural history of the things that are there? Right. Exactly. And I think Cooper says that when he sees these beautiful paintings of the Colosseum, these rare plants that traveled there potentially on the backs of lions, it raises some interesting questions about what state we should preserve a ruin in. Is it just the rocks that the only thing that we care about?
And yeah, that there are stories embedded potentially within other aspects of what's there that tell important parts of the history. Yeah, it does make me sad to think that we've lost the romantic potential of this site of this incredible ruin overgrown with greenery. And also the fact that, you know, there are buried stories hidden in these different layers of history. I'm also in the intangible elements like the floor are growing in a particular ruin can tell like a huge part of the story. So talking to Paul and you know seeing that the Twitter thread that he put together and then later turned into an article it really just made me think about historical preservation and arch- and
archeological preservation and really what gets to be a part of what lives on and what we choose not to leave, what doesn't make the cut. Right. Which in this case is all these plants. I mean, the story of the built world is not just the things we build, it's all the stuff around it, and it could be the natural flora and fauna that it affects. And that's an amazing thing.
Yeah. And there are still some plants in the Colosseum and other know, there are people that make decisions about what to pick and what to weed out. And now there's this whole city that's built up around this space. And so it's even more kind of outliers within the rest of the built environment. It's a little bit of greenery in a gray concrete world. So a while back 99PI's digital director, Kohlstedt, started researching a story about sack cloth dresses. It's a type of DIY clothing made from upcycled flour
and feed sacks. And we considered it for a full episode for a while, but Kurt had a connection to the story that made it even better as a mini story. Homemade sack cloth apparel grew really popular during the Great Depression. But as I was looking into it, I thought the idea seemed familiar somehow.
So I called up this historian I know to see if maybe she had told me about them when I was a bit younger. Okay, so, mom, can you tell us briefly who you are and what you do? I'm Sally Grigney-Colstead. I'm a professor at the University of Minnesota, where I teach courses on science and American culture,
and also courses on women and gender and science. So my mom was born in Michigan during World War II, and her dad worked in Detroit at the time. As soon as I was born, my father was shipped overseas, and so I went home to live with her family on a farm in the thumb of Michigan. So like all people from Michigan,
she refers to the shape of Michigan as looking like a gloved hand, and refers to it as the thumb or where it is in the hand, right? Yeah, and so people if they're trying to tell you where they are from in Michigan, they'll just hold up their hand and like point to part of that. And like other places in America, people in Michigan had developed ways to deal with shortages in the late 1920s and going through World War II. Well, when I was a little girl, my grandmother did most of the sewing for all of us. And so the fabric that she used for what we're called her in-ray day dress was actually
fabric that she would pick out by going to the local general store. So my great grandmother would buy saxophower and then reuse those sax. And the flower sax became then the fabric for these dresses. I mean, was the fabric any, I think I picture the sex that hold rice or something, which are terrible burlap style sex, like what was the fabric like? Well, it actually had to be pretty finely woven because it was made to hold flour. Oh, yeah, I guess that makes sense. It was an all cotton kind of fabric. It's a really decent quality of fabric.
So these days we think of flour as being something that comes in these smaller, five or ten pound bags, often made of paper. But back then it was a different story. There were huge sacks, and I remember they were as big as I was because I had the whole 50 or 100 pounds of flower. So did the flower companies know that people were using their flower sacs and upscaling them as dresses? Yeah, I mean, they started to figure this out over time and they started to adjust their
designs accordingly. And so some of them actually used ink that would wash back out so you could have this clean, white cloth. And others went the other direction with it and they designed these patterns and so you'd buy flower sacs with dancers or jockeys or bunnies or flowers or other interesting things. And my mom's grandmother would see through those options and bring home favorites from the store.
She learned quickly that I didn't like pink. So I think she avoided getting me pink fabric or pink flowers on fabric because she knew what I liked. People at the time also turned sacks into quilts, curtains, even diapers. And farmers reused livestock feed bags too. And that fabric was rougher, but it still worked for things like towels. So my very first sewing experience was taking a piece of that fabric and trimming it
so that we could use it for dish towels. Apparently, my great grandfather had a feedback apron, my great-grandmother made him for doing really really dirty work like two dirty even for work clothes For example helping out cows in labor So you'd buy so you'd buy a sack of feed for the cows and then you'd use that sack to help birth new cows.
That's pretty crazy. That's what I recall. So companies of course caught on to the sack fabric trend and they realized they could boost their sales with nicer cotton and fresh and more sort of fashionable patterns along the way. And some manufacturers even sponsored national sack cloth dressmaking competitions. and fresh and more sort of fashionable patterns along the way. And some manufacturers even sponsored national sackcloth dressmaking competitions. Wow.
That's right. It was very clever marketing as I think about it as a historian. So the first time I talked to my mom about this, she actually said this quote that I really liked, that it was part of the quote, fabric of life, of living in rural America, which seemed, you know, really apt. Ultimately these designs, they evolved beyond just being born of necessity. They became about fashion and identity for these people too, which I think is really fascinating. And so, once I arrived, I could go to a fabric store and buy velvet, a wool, or linen. But woven into ordinary life in these farm communities was going to the general store picking out your fabrics
and then trying not to pick out the same fabric as some neighbor might have. Because no matter what, even if you're wearing a dress man, I have sack cloth, you want to look good, you want to have it express yourself, that's like a universal thing. In some cases they'd buy a batch of bags, bring them home, and everybody in the same family would be kind of wearing
the same patterns of sack loss. You could actually tell who was from what family by the patterns that they were wearing. Like a tartan, like a kilter. Exactly, exactly. Like a modern day kilter. That's so cool. This has been really great. I love talking to you about this. I love the fact that my mom's a historian, and it is just so interested in these things.
And has these great sort of personal histories too. Thank you so much, Mom, for agreeing to do this and talking to me about this. Well, I think 99% of the visible is terrific, and I'm happy to be part of any part of it. That's so great, Mom. I love you a lot, give my best to dad, and I'll talk to you soon, okay?
Okay, I love you too, Kurt, bye-bye. Bye. Oh, it's a great journey. Oh, I love it. Avery, who helped me get set up with all this, she was like, okay, you can cut any part of the C-Won, but you've got to keep that. You've got to keep that sign off. That's why she knows what she's doing every.
Yeah. Alright, thanks so much. Since the beginning of the year, astute listeners who will listen all the way to the end of the show, you're my favorite nerds, the nerds who listen all the way to the beginning of the year, a stuute listeners who listen all the way to the end of the show, you're my favorite nerds, the nerds who listen all the way to the end of the show, you may have noticed a new production credit since we started using all original music. Since I've had your voice on here, why don't you actually introduce yourself and what you do at the show? I'm Sean Rial and I'm the composer for I do all the music.
Cool. And so you have a mini story. This is your first mini story. It's my first radio story ever. At all. There we go. Okay, well, congratulations. So let's hear it.
So it's the late 1800s and people are just starting to consume recorded music. And the process of recording at this time is kind of hectic, and I like to imagine a lot of fun, but maybe more hectic. So before they used microphones and studios, sound was captured by these big horns, which were made of like mainly brass or copper, and these recording horns would collect and focus the sound vibrations into this little diaphragm, and the diaphragm would vibrate a stylus that cut a groove into a wax disc. Should I be picturing these recording horns pretty much like a phonograph, like an old fashioned phonograph that plays out through one of these horns?
Yeah, it's like the same thing except just backwards. Okay, cool. Yeah, so yeah, that's like part of it is just same backwards as forwards. But the problem with this process was that these recording horns were limited in what sound frequencies they'd respond to. So certain instruments like tubas and French horns which were also made of brass
will get picked up much louder than string instruments like guitars or violins. Or that makes sense. So nowadays we record every instrument on its own track and do a lot of leveling after the fact, but back then they had to record whole orchestras with just one or sometimes two, if they were really fancy, of these big recording horns in a single room. And then they just make copies of the disc that they recorded on. There was no editing.
If there was too much French horn or if an opera singer like, you know, blew out the recording with their falsetto, you throw the disc away and you do it again. So in order to get a balanced mix of different instruments and voices, sound engineers would arrange the musicians all around the studio at various distances from the recording horns. Sometimes they'd have the louder instruments, like French horns, pointed at the back wall away from the recording horn, and the musicians would be watching their conductor
like in a mirror. Wow. And they put pianos on top of a platform so that the mallets and chords that are inside would be lined up with the recording horn, and this one's one of my favorites. They'd sometimes put a singer like on a little trolley so that an assistant could wheel them closer to the horn for quieter vocal passages and wheel them away during loud ones.
That sounds chaotic, it's like a Rube Goburg recording of an orchestra. That's amazing. Okay. But the string instruments were the hardest to record. And because of that, like stand-up bass parts were often just played on tuba instead. And a lot of engineers didn't want to deal with recording violins at all. So there were very few recordings with violins on them before a certain time. Is that true?
Well, there were actually a fair amount of recordings with violins, but it was part because of the engineers going through all this trouble to do these elaborate sessions, but also because of this. Oh my God. OK, so could you describe what you're holding? I'm holding Astro violin, which my bandmate found at this novelty music shop, and it's got the neck
and head and bridge of a violin and the strings, but instead of a body, it's just got this wooden rod, and then this huge horn that's coming out of it. So imagine a violin with no, what do you call it the body that has the, you know, like we think of that resonates that goes up against your neck when you play a violin. That's all gone.
And then instead is this, basically a trumpet sitting on, you know, pointed, you know, folded back into itself and the sound comes out of the end of the trumpet horn. Just like how recording was like the gramophone backwards. This is also the same concept of the gramophone. The vibrating of the strings goes into this diaphragm that's down here by the bridge
and it vibrates the sound which gets projected out by the horn. Wow, that's amazing. It looks really, it would be the centerpiece of a steampunk orchestra basically. Yeah, there are there are steampunk bands that that use this You want to hear what it sounds like? I would love to That's awesome. In a way in its native state, like in this room, it kind of sounds like an old recording of a violin because it's going through that diaphragm and horn and it has a little bit
of a electroacoustic sort of seeming processing. Yeah, and that's part of it is that the reason why recording sound that way is because that's what the old recording horns were able to pick up. Right. And so what this was doing was it was actually just amplifying the frequencies that the recording horns would pick up.
Right, so it was designed to speak to the horn that is doing the recording in some ways. Like it's the analog, the match on the other side of it to make it even better to be picked up. Yeah. Another thing that it did was it actually, like, the horn, it made the sound more directional because all of these musicians had to like funnel their sounds like into this like one acoustic horn in the corner of the room. It was really helpful when you could have a violin that would point it sound directly at the horn rather than just radiating out into the room, which is what the resonant body usually does.
Oh, that's awesome. And for a little while, it was a big deal in the recording industry. These designs were applied to all kinds of instruments, drove guitars, drove cellos, drove mandalins, drove ukuleles, and actually a lot of instruments that weren't under the strobe name, but there were just a lot of different instruments from different companies that utilize this design. And strobe is the brand name. Yeah, strobe is the name of the person
who invented the first one. He was John Matthias Augustus Stroh. And so were they all manufactured by a company that was the Stroh Company? Or was it just a design that was used by anybody? Yeah, I was the Stroh Violin Company and they kept manufacturing them even past Stroh's death in 1914. His son picked up where he left off. There were a lot of articles that were speculating about where it fit into the broader world of music. Like this one in Strand Magazine from 1902 that I found that was pushing hard that these
instruments were the future. The harmonics are loud and pure, but what is of great importance is an entire absence of scrape. This is a point that solo players will value highly. Of course, the idea of a new violin that can be played upon immediately is finished, and that will produce marvelous tone and quality of sound will possibly come as a shock to old-fashioned people during the original violin has been a cherished idol, but the spirit of invention respects no one's prejudices. And those are actually phonophiddles playing underneath, which are kind of a relative to
the strobe island. That's awesome. So I say you have one, but what happened to these instruments in the larger world? So around 1925, electric microphone technology made its way into recording studios and broader ranges of instruments became more possible to capture. So these modified instruments no longer like, you know, made the same practical sense of recording industry. So the Strav Island company slowed production and then finally shut down in 1942.
You tell them sad about it. I can't tell. And a lot of people write about them is kind of like the silly flash in the pan thing, but they were a really valuable tool for the beginnings of the recording industry. And without them, there are a lot of records where violins, like, wouldn't have been as present probably. Or studios just like wouldn't have bothered to record them at all. So after they weren't necessary
because recording technology had advanced, did they just kind of fizzle out as an instrument? Well, they're actually still around. Oh, like you can find them in wide use and folk music from Romania or Myanmar. Shakira, you had a Strow violin player as part of her 2010-2011 tour. And resonator guitars, you know, those ones
with like the partly metal bodies and they got kind of like the nice designs like that into that. Yeah, totally. So those are the same technology as the Strobe Island. And one of the inventors of the resonator guitar had visited the Strobe factory like in its heyday. And there are a number of articles that say
that he based his designs off what he saw there. So it still lives on to this day. And what is it that you, I mean you said you're a little sad about it, but why are you sad? What does it do for you? What do you enjoy about it? Well, I think what I feel sad about is that it's just so different than a violin. And the strand magazine article was trying to be like, this is better than the violin. And of course, you know, like, violins, which had been around for a long time to be like, this is like better than the violin. And of course, you know, like violins which have been around,
had been around for a long time are like, no better than a violin. I mean, it's actually kind of a little bit more limited range by definition than a violin, but it has a really kind of, there's something nice about that sound. Yeah, it's a different kind of range of frequencies. I don't know, I just think that like it's wonderful to have like different kinds of sounds. Right. So yeah. Cool. Well thanks for introducing us to the Strove Island. That's amazing. Thank you, Romain. We're going to take a quick break and I'll catch you up on a couple notable stories in the
flurry of flag redesigns that were catalyzed by the TED Talk I gave a couple years back. Stay tuned. So in March of 2015, I did a main stage TED Talk where I talked about the design of flags and how many city flags around the country were particularly awful. And I performed it live, like a live podcast on the TED stage. And I used the voice of Vexelon Eric extraordinaire Ted K to explain his flag design principles and it was a total blast and What's great is that since then there have been over a hundred flag redesigns in the US And it's been fun to watch people engage with their civic symbols in a new way
Burlington Vermont had an open call flag redesign contest to replace their coat of arm style flag And the competition was won by twin 12-year-old brothers, Owen and Lucas Martiso. It's a white, green, and white zigzag stripe on a blue field. It's a very handsome flag. Congrats, guys. A particular note in the flagry design world
is the flag of Pocahtello, Idaho. Pocahtello was voted the worst city flag in North America by the members of the North American Vexelological Association, and it was kind of the punchline of the TED Talk. And after they heard about the talk, they invited me up to Pocotello to spur their flag redesign efforts. And they couldn't have been nicer and more gracious at a fantastic time there.
I had breakfast with the mayor. CBS Sunday morning came to Pocotello to do a national news piece about their redesign. And I think, even though, you know though I was having a little fun with them, the city came away from the experience really excited and enjoyed the attention. And best of all, after our year-long effort, they got a new beautiful flag. The new flag is called mountains left and it has three red peaks symbolizing three local mountains on a field of blue and a blue line at the bottom that represents the port enough river and at the top of the highest peak is a golden compass rose representing Poca de la Transportation History.
It is a fine flag. I hope to see it everywhere next time I'm up there. If you're curious to see a picture of it, Google, it's 2017, just like you use your phone. But we'll also have a picture of it on our website at 99pi.org. Well done, Poca de la. It was a real honor to be your guest.
We're going to take a little break until 2018, but I'm going to put some surprise 99pi stories on the feet that I know you'll dig, so you might not even notice we're going. Have a happy new year. We'll be back in 2018 with another mini-stories installment featuring the rest of the crew and a couple of this new suggested stories as well. See you then. 99% of visible is Avery Trollfmann, Emmith Fitzgerald, Sharif Yusuf, Delaney Hall,
Taren Mazza, composer Sean Rial, senior producer Katie Mingle, digital director Kurt Colstead, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Knight Foundation and sticker-loving listeners, just like you.
You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork or on Instagram Tumblr and Reddit too. But the real 99PI HQ is at 99PI dot org. Radio TepiRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.